hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be breaking down the latest disturbing
installment of the mha story shigaraki
is an absolute monster and he may have
just stolen the world's strongest quirk
our thick queen of freedom stars and
stripes might have just lost her life
sicko mode shigaraki somehow survived a
hydrogen bomb level blast and things
will never be the same in boku no hero
after this world altering battle so
let's get into it if you guys enjoy our
boku no hero content and you want us to
keep it going you know what to do just
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it actually helps a
lot and while you're there smashing that
like button don't forget to subscribe
and hit the bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't subscribe hit
that bell and then select the option
that says all you're gonna miss a ton of
our videos it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror finally this
video will of course contain boku no
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned the
previous chapter ended with a clearly
injured shigaraki pinned down under the
foresaw medikachan's laser spear
wielding susano and at the same time
those tiamat hypersonic missiles were
headed to the area so after that high
intensity cliffhanger moment the new
chapter starts off with a flashback
because of course but don't worry it's
not a long flashback and the chapter is
still absolutely nuts and full of action
the flashback shows a younger america
chan looking upset that she couldn't
increase her own strength to make
herself as strong as all might she tried
various different rules and phrasing
them in various different ways but
despite the fact that her quirk appears
to be able to do anything it does have
limits and one of those limits is the
extent to which the user can increase
their own strength some people who knew
about her quirk used to ask her if maybe
she couldn't make herself stronger
because she herself wasn't strong enough
to begin with maybe she just didn't have
enough innate strength talent and
potential required to be as strong as
all might and some even implied that the
fact that she's a woman had something to
do with it but america chan's brothers
the members of her unit never doubted
her for a second they said that she
can't be the problem so it must be the
quirk and if there is anything that she
can't do because of her quirks
limitations then her team will back her
up and they will accomplish it together
by the way the official translation on
viz.com translated her name as cassie
not kathy so that's something to keep in
mind going forward i'm not sure if
cassie is her real name or if that's
short for cassandra but either way i'll
probably just keep calling her america
chan and freedom waifu the flashback
ends with the members of amerika chan's
team telling her that she is already
strong and that she needs to stop
comparing herself to all might both she
and all might are absolute monsters and
she doesn't need to worry about catching
up to him she just needs to keep
following her own path and continue
being the amazing hero that she is man
that is great advice and these guys are
true bros i wish my friends were that
supportive but i'm friends with nax taku
so that's never gonna happen anyway this
quick flashback establishes the fact
that amerika chan's team always had her
back and that they were always there for
her she feels incredibly close to them
and she cares about them a lot and that
will become important later on in the
chapter as those missiles approach the
jets continue shooting lasers at
chigaraki while stars and stripes
initiates the next stage of their plan
she lets go of the laser bending rule
that she had been using to concentrate
the lasers into one gigantic and
powerful spear and she then proceeds to
grab those tiamat missiles using the
power of her quirk she is able to
concentrate all of the missiles together
into one tight formation she then grabs
them with her susano form and smashes
them all at once into shigaraki's
already injured body this results in an
absolutely gigantic explosion that looks
like a freaking hydrogen bomb just went
off i mean this explosion is beyond
massive and even endeavour who is still
far away from the blast site can see it
in the distance and he is completely
shocked by what he sees the explosion
leaves behind a gigantic crater that
looks like an asteroid had crashed into
the earth or something and judging by
everything that we've seen so far in
terms of power scaling in mha no
character in the series should have been
able to survive such an unprecedented
level of destruction this attack which
was a combination of one of the
strongest quirks and some of the
strongest man-made weapons in existence
is easily the most powerful attack we've
ever seen in the series nevertheless
once the smoke clears america chan
notices that at the very bottom of the
giant crater there is a deep dark hole
and then out of that hole a skeletal
looking shigaraki suddenly emerges his
body has been destroyed down to the bone
but his super regeneration is already
working overtime and as a result his
grotesquely mangled body is already
beginning to recover with a sick grin on
his face shigaraki leaps towards stars
and stripes using her own jets as
footholds his internal monologue reveals
that shigaraki had used his perfect
control of awakened decay to tunnel deep
underground by hiding far beneath the
surface at just the right moment
shigaraki managed to survive the blast
if his timing had been even a
millisecond off he would have been
killed in that massive explosion i mean
at this point it's safe to assume that
one of the quirks that offer one
transferred to shigaraki during his
procedure was called plot armor at this
rate the final battle between dekko and
chigaraki will be a showdown between two
different types of plot armor and it's
gonna be absolutely insane as shigaraki
gets closer to amerikachan her squadron
scrambles to return to their formations
they are all committed to protecting
stars and stripes at any cost for his
part shigaraki is absolutely determined
to steal new orders so that he can put
it to better use and that is especially
the case for the all for one personality
within shigaraki all for one is
desperate to steal new order and the
harder that stars and stripes fights
against him the more obsessed he becomes
with stealing her quirk at one point
shigaraki jumps on top of the jet that
is closest to america chan and he
prepares to use it as his final foothold
to reach her the pilots of that jet
immediately tell stars and stripes to
use her susano form to crush both
shigaraki and the jet at the same time
even though this would kill the pilots
themselves the ensuing explosion could
be strong enough to kill shigaraki since
he hasn't still been able to fully
regenerate if shigaraki sustains a heavy
amount of damage at this point in time
he might actually be defeated american
is clearly thinking about it she's
preparing herself and her susanoo to end
both shigaraki and the jet in a fiery
inferno but then in the very last moment
she thinks about her team and how much
she cares about them she thinks about
how these guys her brothers were there
for her through thick and thin and how
they had her back no matter what in the
end cassie decides that she just can't
do it she can't sacrifice the lives of
her brothers in order to kill shigaraki
as a result of her hesitation shigaraki
manages to reach her he grabs her face
with his right hand and that is how this
unbelievable chapter ends the text on
the final page states those hands
managed to reach their target what is
the outcome of this decisive battle whoa
is this really happening shigaraki
surviving a hydrogen bomb is one thing
but is horikoshi really about to kill
off another thick waifu no horikoshi
don't do it man mirko and lady nagant
were severely injured we lost midnight
we lost the female nomu don't do it man
i know that a lot of people are
speculating that this could be the end
for stars and stripes and yeah if
shikaki were to use decay on her now he
could likely kill her on the spot but
the all-for-one personality inside of
shiitake doesn't want to kill her not
until he can steal her quirk so that is
exactly what he will attempt to do now
the big question is will he succeed or
will something happen before the quirk
stealing process can be completed how
long does this quirk stealing process
last anyway and how much time if any
needs to pass between all for one
stealing a quirk and being able to
effectively use it with a complex quirk
like new order does he need some time to
activate it master it and use it
properly or can he just start using it
as soon as he steals it the answers to
these questions will determine what
happens next and they will also
determine the ultimate fate of america
chad definitely let me know down in the
comments what you guys think is going to
happen next assuming that chicago won't
kill stars and stripes right away
because he needs to steal her quirk
first can members of her team do
something to stop him from stealing new
order even at the risk of their own
lives or can maybe endeavour arrive in
time to stop shigaraki now that he knows
where the battle is taking place did
stars and stripes maybe impose a new
rule on herself that we don't know about
because it happened off-screen a rule
that could save her life and her quirk
in the next chapter finally what do you
guys think about the crazy power
escalation that took place during this
epic showdown between shigaraki and
stars and stripes after this we can
expect that the scale of all major
battles going forward is going to be far
beyond the battles that we saw in the
past and the mha we used to know is
pretty much dead small scale battles and
low stakes arcs are a thing of the past
and that means that major destruction
and major deaths are likely coming soon
this really feels different it really
feels like the build up to the end of
the entire story and personally i am
both excited and worried about what's
going to happen next if you guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more boku
no hero videos in the future please
leave that like it only takes a second
but it helps a lot and if you're new to
anime out pro or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at anime opera
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thank you to alpha
sigma this man is an absolute mad lad
and a disciple of lord twego himself i
also can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata algital
pate heffa hinokami and water the
toasted cheek corey mcgowan the spike
kaido might be a gyarados dylan isidor
spidey life tinel tungsten tarkis baked
buddhist monkey d quilly cody hebert and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven steelers on hell crews very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joanne
garcia fat boy games jessica rabbit and
jeremy phillips if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value to
you consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you